hello grammarians hello paige hi david
so we have three different sentence
varieties that we're going to talk about
today all right um here are their three
flavors
flavor number one declarative sentences
uh flavor number two
interrogative
sentences
and uh flavor number three
imperative sentences
those are all pretty long and wibbly
words seriously um but we will address
each one of them in turn
page if you please
what is a declarative sentence
a declarative sentence is a type of
sentence that just states
a fact or an opinion i suppose but it
just it just makes a statement
so that would be something like
it is a beautiful day
is a beautiful day paige we can also use
declarative sentences to just get across
any kind of information this is what we
call exposition in writing yeah you know
so we could say
lavender hated baseball you know you
could start a short story with that
right that's challenge you two just a
fact about about lavender that's a fact
about lavender so a declarative sentence
is
a statement just straight up yeah
an interrogative sentence is a question
so it asks
a question so it's just a fancy word for
a question right okay so an example of
an interrogative sentence would be you
know where did you go last night right
or how is he still singing that note i
have no idea incredible breath control
so that's that's what an interrogative
question is right it's like
being interrogated that's like a similar
word to interrogative is just having a
lot of questions asked like really
aggressively yeah it's not a very
positive thing paige what did you do
with the cheese i don't know paige why
are you still eating the cheese i'm not
paige i know you stole the cheese
finally the third kind of sentence we
want to talk about today is the
imperative
an imperative is a command
right so when you tell someone to do
something so a command
like paige follow that bunny
i think the bunny stole the cheese yeah
so this is one of those sentences that
doesn't have um a subject that is
literally spoken out loud right it's
just implied you know
if if you're saying that to me i know
that i am the subject right so it's you
follow that bunny right but the you is
just not spoken
or
if you're not into bunny following you
know something like remember to wash the
dishes you're still you're being
commanded to remember yeah yeah so yeah
that's our that's those are our three
sentence types yeah declarative is a
statement interrogative is a question
and imperative is a command so paige i
think we can recast our slogan
uh in each of these three types of
sentence okay so okay so declarative
right that's that's what it usually is
declarative form is you can learn
anything okay uh we can make it a
question so interrogative so can you
learn anything right the answer is yes
uh and the imperative we want to make it
a command would be what page
learn anything yeah
so you can do any of those three sure uh
dave it out page out